aunque no hay una solución a la vista a
la crisis migratoria entre polonia y
belarús el presidente alexander
lukashenko hizo una primera apuesta
después de acercamientos telefónicos con
la canciller alemana angela merkel y
ahora pisa el mecanismo que ofreció el
presidente fue el siguiente la unión
europea creará un corredor humanitario
para dos mil refugiados que se
encuentran en el campamento nos
comprometemos a ayudar a los otros cinco
mil tanto como sea posible y en caso de
que estén dispuestos a regresar a casa
son orgullosos pero el plan todavía no
tiene luz verde del bloque comunitario
joyce nuca
nicosia en guys
lukashenko rising no se trata de
negociar con el régimen de lukashenko lo
que anunciamos ayer es que mantendremos
conversaciones técnicas con las agencias
de la onu en particular con acnur y la
oim y las contrapartes bielorrusas con
el fin de facilitar la repatriación de
las personas que se encuentran en la
frontera
con el lugar
la unión europea ha pedido la
intervención del presidente ruso
vladimir quien ha mostrado su apoyo a
lukashenko
no podemos dejar de ver que los países
occidentales se utilizan la crisis
migratoria en la frontera bielorrusa
polaca como una nueva razón para la
atención en nuestra región vecina para
ejercer presión sobre minsk y al mismo
tiempo olvidan sus propias obligaciones
humanitarias
un minuto es necio unos 500 migrantes
intentaron cruzar hacia territorio de la
unión europea otros abandonaron la
misión más de 400 iraquíes retornaron a
bagdad en un vuelo de repatriación
la situación de alrededor de 7 mil
migrantes empeora con el pasar de los
días atrapados o escondidos a lo largo
de la frontera esperan por su suerte
bajo temperaturas gélidas que ya han
cobrado varias vidas